there will be growth in the global
economy in 2009 even in the United
States I think in the second half you're
going to start to see little signs of
recovery the global economy was smashed
as was the US economy by the financial
crisis if the new administration just
gets a few things right or stops making
mistakes by the law of averages we are
due for some good decisions from
Washington this thing will let us start
to whether basic strength to start to
come through for example one of the
things the Obama administration get get
rid of business of strange accounting
rule called mark-to-market just
devastated bank balance sheets what bank
makes alone now it knows it's probably
going to have to take a hit to its
capital because even if the principal is
being paid interest is being paid banks
if they have to sell the loan tomorrow
which they won't but the regulator's
come in and say if you had a sub alone
tomorrow what price would you get have
to take a writedown on which is crazy
we'd have that rule in the early 90s any
of the banking crisis we destroyed most
major commercial banks in the United
States so get rid of mark to market and
that way banks and rebuild their balance
sheets and the other thing much anything
administration will do it's right up the
rallies government activism is that the
housing market revived by having you to
the Federal Reserve or Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac go to banks and say we'll
buy your mortgages any mortgages you
write with a fixed interest rate of four
and a half five percent long-term rates
are low now for mortgages but you thanks
aren't making the loans but if they know
they can sell the mortgages that many
and Freddie or to other federal reserve
they'll start writing those loans again
get the housing market movie so a couple
of basic things like that would ill a
long ways and get things moving